work on my neighbor back to class
super excited to talk to yo too d to
how you going to discuss
seminar very interesting pop x first
we're going to be nice sam on the horse
laying there then finish the last
lecture and think  year going to the dean
when the theory of count neural networks
hide so led
we build here and this welding tongs wise last and you
soon grab it duo design grave now the
networks
what can you do design choices to you
make a golden your set up  the entire
let's go let training inference
pipeline and who takes all your set
up the input graf how to the fine de
Graaf neural network architecture
get more expensive use it to create distress en
mennings en take your guys picked up times
attitude getver distress introduction to the
pernix  save a floor and who
talked about the difference prediction
and
bij is dan never classification a link
prediction if ever craft
classification we talked about how you
then make predictions keep your bowl  per
dose per dixons with grande back
labels on dima is the las function and b
must the mouth propagation red wine down
to the pressure off now rené park structure
and denyo we already grabbed two slides can
job evaluation matrixx search news
by a16 meet de  performance of your
nice warm see that silent belt once on
amsterdam
how to be set around the bag shoulder you
properly split into the training we wali
dation in test set and what he wants her
suit in the spark of the lecture is address
that smash a golden trim  metal er
d'etat sets older krabbé at the time in to
train walid action and test 6 so who
gives options
i am who year splitting kd bags who
can split about details says that was
and kool isafix split
with which she kimono tkd tight and speaking
to  three years this joint independent
pieces
wimona gemma training set with mia going
to use to optimize jane and model
parameters
more going to use a lead nation set
offers growth
week and youstoub yong hai couple
param  eaters and marius chance or could be
constant the season choices and
in terms of the modeling the architecture
and ones
basically using the training set and the
body dation sedley finalize our final
final final various of hype er
parameters final wine box of different
design at minions
who her think  going to apply our money
to this you independent testset
with was no download time and we'll
use it to report final
performance and the sea ze off their way
to evaluate the cosby use training en
balinese en to be je de model
danny ficus de magn  and jaap like to the
independent aan scene
network touch the for a test 6 and
rita you ran your gate of all
performance what is interesting' in
count is that
some times i cannot guarantee that the
test set will really be give your
opinion that there is now  be no information
leakey from training van walibi insights
into the tests and this is why this
becomes interesting' zo lets intern
sulphur fix spliet
was gone have created and that  i split who
could actually make it sucks a typical
Rijndam and what this kind of minis that
lack microrendu did not over do a to
training bali animal be their best and
am i good can that for that gate
reinder then think to singlespeed now
culture report something performance  about
diferent
leds do good random striker so little
just to create the split inwork who is not
for him there the other one can or
creator the split what warm component of
bed split is that there is some random
so and weekend and run alkmene that
strange  instance you of the split and
report the greek to brighten you my
more robust there was so to here noailles
speaks in grave special a major
unforgiven
image detail are or a document details
and then in such details at us you dat
did lines are independent from  each
other
so deep news that every detail here is
something new
and then because there the payment
of god there is something easy to freedom in the
training test and validate and
set to  in technology kick back as each
a week is that deetos did a point
bytes om to
splitting of count is that fruit to the
problems de count is that notes are
connected to each other
such a collection emergency classification
did something that point is an al nou  to
buddy's note god independent wit formica
der
de notes are actually connected to each
other
and so die smith that there is a need for
hot and for how you effect
the production of om or distress 5 sorry because
where the training day bags and 5 is the
tess did that are then clearly
we go together information lieke zo
this is why the  seas' interest inc sold
and the question is what our options
mark and who what can you do to who can
do the following to the for solutions
is to do what record
osteoarthritis active setting where the input
graff king die  surf on
or for the details it's so basically
who-who-who warp the his grave structure
for training
wally this and test and who wants oil
split the ailing no labels opinion
will keep the count structure as is only
two years going to put some notes  in
through the training test and the counter dation
set so via oil splitting arno bremers
die smith that and the training time
who computer is at hand or never let's
a one and to be precious about
training set using the a paragraph what
oil labels or when to and
aqualillies and time i computer meddings
or the in pie grave and oil and wine you
know to labels or notes tree and for
picos understand the data for them to this
to be one possible at road to this
to other pro is what piccola
annie and active setting  where who break
the edges at in the splits
in to move people graff for this
olim deep and the count smoothie poly rib
and
landcomponent so narrow wych-elm free cross that there is a
deep and the and in our case law could mean
i  thought i would just draw
this file parents so well who gives an
idea of the count and you can cola after
training grave of ali dation like a
crane so disney that my name who
her opinion with ca prediction
in the test set about another five years of need
effects the at the
prediction of at the label orden
structure from information for no one
en humor zo so who is that the
training time i computer weddings oil
over de graaf the test for emergency
housing and oil and using the labels or
when to and the  aqualillies en time
mecom pewdie en weining using de graaf
about distress stream for in the wwb are the
note 3 a pro or cost problem medici
de mini's red is that well he went he
gives roon ow quite a few wedges quite a
bit of graaf information and leaf  my
grafters beautiful this is not
brief there so small on the steps advice
because of this he her family king of
structure information the queen training
wali dation in test set what that is not the
labels there independent in the tra  nce
active setting
hear someone active saving ajax lie there
influx a way the edges so that he job
the count into the strange independent
pieces and then run or and we now week
over by skewers so in the solution in
the transaction your setting is that the in
input
can be on surf especially az striker
training wali animal put on a vest and
this is the seas interesting' they chose
an
iittala essence to basic you operating
the [ __ ] you could also think already
semi super wise setting were graphically
new
delay gadgets or for  the need new
the features for the nose archives what
the lion
at the labels of distress why that sonia
step or one on labels is on care
so hard to summarize in the transactions
setting understand training test in bali
bugs
i hear londersele grave became did
acoustic  of one connector the count the
entire kraft can be to itself in order did
a split something like that minus solid nut oil
theaters and order emergency features
bak biology speaks the de  labels opinion
sam labels arm itself other a bunch of
labels absurd and this setting is
applica boog donald prediction
if we as excuse expedition bags
i think your setting songs the
training balinese and test sets
aaron deeper in graphs the details have
no consist of trouble programs  it there
indipendent from each other
who you on the same count structure
distress features
as ever a legging never labels
that served split
to sat in that room when ritesh
could generalized icing grass the the
dream back of the throat
is that who says i pass  regional
graff and joke piet into many different
small pieces and the swiss roll slowly add
information such as nou
international classification
gerardi bionex approach intense or trance
roof thief classification music
publique note in the training bali dation and
test set
in the inductive setting to whom
basically the  can assume the no bother
positive rent
graphs and glam
en week a take some graf in d  e
training are different in the waal ideas
and best
don't bother paul grice who
gives on create must that polygraph where
this q drop in the hedge orca team diet
so with less so media this is rather
and connect components and then powder
less training  test in walibi set so
namely a g-pak cabau distress
classification led switch and let's go
to the next up classification bag
switches
in the training wali bit of
a test sets so basically brush and chaos
in for the training set sam in the desk
dation set and some in the best so
time busy in giving independent also raven
is talking about something then there is
also a crosstalk there is  still information the
click on and this can be done
burg apps on the trick first or front door
and settings for machine there in white
cross link production
to my the goal of quite
perfectionists product the missing
gadgets and the setting up new addiction
and requires a bit of luck and i can be
tricky because link prediction is up to
super white horse and supervise do
n't rush to create labels and the details
pleats om our om zo die clever
minute  how do you go the some of the ages
from the gray and en en suffering jane and
predict the i system gadgets so that is
ideal for disasters that of ginger
by regional graff
he gives access couple of er so for
jumper die store ad dekkers so he
said  who is the input and a want my
my jane and problem want to predict
the chair output edges already in some
things will have to take some major
crimes and from our sales and bright to
predict do zo dc's interesting' I
already on this more complex  city
beacause om in ijn and michiel
tie-fighters
who will sms xfashion gadgets riders through
the green and can use to cradle opinion and
think i have that weak my code
supervision and those which of the ages
that horse or flats hr training
better them so for link pernix and minutes
split enterprise
in first step to assign to time for
pages to do the 10 euro als x and c major
sauerkraut solid brass neat the year
sometime use for the jane and to operate
about in den muloschool
what their coal supervision ages
wiardi rodgers for as the computer jack the
function las function
performance of the module will on and
behind the city was an oil messengers
family opinion de count and supervision
ages earth agency with aryans for
supervision or
expedition made  by domo do and will not
be used by the journey aan
zo so this is the step and then in the
sec a star we split
agency to train
test en waal idea of set to and
admit actions what to do what is good in
the active link prediction speaks
where economic just said who he was
details out of nowhere triglav
and i split may be in the power bi on
in the pain the gladly so again hammer
training set
we all have an idea  tions art and a
fast set 3 I would rather have a power and a
graff
that friend split in
terms of training walid asian and
at the time right so geer die should be the
magic special gaiters in the supervision
m so in the second wali nation
graf hier  well again her different and
supervision eaters and different methods
passing thou leaders and the in the test set
so i zo this one way and to this and
other way to this is to this in the
trance active sec i and icidu trance roof
public predictions offers  this is
generally that die for 2 people talk
about link production and suppose don't want
heroine one input please what you have to
do in this one to input please at the
finish and that trance dak team or the
what am i not doing both platforms active
learning the  entire graff went on who
takes care of the details at striker
what do you see health and safety horse or de Graaf
structure and the supervision minute
started old
wali dation and per sets on and think
oh trained training set minutes past
met and the superleague their parents
under training set seems to me a
show you calling say now matters is so
on seriousness active sound pernix
only link prediction library or
region each other and who her going to
create a training details adware want
him a couple of  training gadget for msx
version as we pass the supervision and
juice aqualillies and time where would
use the training knowledge and the training
message passing gadgets and training
supervision
agence the problem with to predict the
counter dation edges and b to the tests
uptime grown to use the  training magic
charger training superhero neat as ever
wali animal neat
to predict the test drivers so now you can
see how
the training time the graphic purple
edges of idea of pain
not who gets [ __ ] the supervision
ends what we care to predict the
validation neat and on  the final best
time we get to see all the ages bar de
pers edges and we need to predict
the bullies  u this
cube sets
arm esther that man to another so to why
would use a growing number of er so i
was one week to think of the thief
is love graphic what shop where time
de nu coetzee had she more the time the
as de count
then  i grew by adding this so that
the count did not save him from address and so
long and so for will you can buy those
sonos goodies
splitting not long series into the
three different time interludes and that
begins the best way to the fine
link prediction  anagram zo to summarize
transaction big predictions politicians
offers
tricky bicos who does not think through
regional graf seriousness and basically cool
for pipes of ages training magics
passing chalks circle supervision and
just one day she neat as wella's
per testers and who gleize here a
do this  in mind reverence cumbersome from
the split around this allows to to to to to
the two things was beacause understand
a good cause meaning deep snap and count
jean dat allah was to this for free  porn
for as
so hard to summarize knew who talked
about by a couple begin in training
pipeline
from www symetrix las functions labels
as we read the predictions
and these are some of the tools you can
news that blue is the account of
managed in an age door  a fresh
zo to summarize who talked about to the
jinn and learn and go do you bankrupt
who talked about how does pack that
friend jane and layer stick and there
and then you'll ever behind the grave or
my dation intense or cycle around my
tank  off structure also minus this one and what
he takes a name was about learning
objectifs and the towel set up the
friend fantastic